[Music]
back in April straight payments released
a new billing platform that makes
complex subscription payments easier
than ever to demonstrate this tool we're
going to build a pretty ambitious
feature a subscription plan that doesn't
get billed on a fixed rate but rather
based on the user's volume of usage
within the app the goal is to give you a
foundation for building your own
software as a service type application
that has a pay-as-you-go payment plan if
you're new here make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and also a little later today
at 1:00 p.m. Pacific Time or 7:00 p.m.
GMT I will be appearing on the angular
Academy show so make sure to register so
you can live chat with myself and the
world-famous David East to get started
with this project you'll need to have a
stripe account and we'll be making heavy
use of firebase functions there's a new
tool in firebase that makes a feature
like this much easier to build than it
was a few months ago and that's thanks
to callable functions basically a
callable function is just like an HTTP
function except that it sends the
context for the authenticated user this
is extremely powerful because it means
you don't have to set your own
authorization headers in the front end
or have to decode them on the back end
which means a lot less code to write and
test will be writing three different
cloud functions so let's walk through
this step-by-step the first one is an
auth function that happens after the
user logs in and sets up their account
with a stripe customer ID after we have
the customer ID set up the next major
milestone is to collect a payment source
and sign up a user for the subscription
plan will implement stripe elements to
collect and validate the credit card
from the user then when they click the
submit payment button it will trigger
our callable function with the auth
context so we can securely attach that
credit card to the user in our back-end
that signs the user up for the plan and
writes a bunch of information to their
fire store user document but at this
point their estimated bill is zero
because they haven't actually done
anything in the app in this particular
app we will charge the user one dollar
per month for every project that they
create if we click this create project
button it will create a document fire
store which again triggers another cloud
function this third and final cloud
function will report usage to stripe so
we know what to build them for again
so if we create a couple more projects -
you'll see that our estimated bill jumps
up to $3.00 per month and we can also
see this in the stripe dashboard where
we have an upcoming invoice for $3.00
for the subscriber and we can inspect
all the usage events which again will
get reported via our cloud function
before we write any code let's start
with the fun part which is setting up
the actual billing plan and stripe the
first thing you'll do is set up your
product which is an entity that can hold
multiple payment plans so for example a
pro subscription would be my product and
then I might have multiple plans for
weekly monthly or quarterly for this
demo here we'll just set up a single
payment plan and we'll make sure to make
it a metered usage plan there's a whole
bunch of ways you can customize the plan
for example you might have tiers for
different levels of volume usage or you
might have different ways of aggregating
the actual usage through the payment
period the whole idea behind stripe
billing is to allow you the developer to
build a complex payment system without
having to write a whole bunch of code to
maintain it
when you're finished you'll have a
product ID and a plan ID make a note of
the plan ID because we'll need that
later in the cloud function now we're
going to switch gears into our angular
app and initialize firebase cloud
functions you'll want to select the
typescript option just go with the
defaults and everything else then see
the end of the functions directory and
run NPM install stripe then the other
thing we need to do is set up our stripe
secret key in the cloud functions
environment you can find it on the
stripe dashboard and I would recommend
using that test data so you're not
actually working with live payment
information then run firebase functions
config set stripe secret with your
secret key and this will securely store
it in our functions environment at this
point we're going to be jumping back and
forth between our front-end and back-end
code so I'll do my best to keep that
clear but the first thing we'll do is
implement our front-end user
authentication code I'm going to go over
that quickly because I cover it in
detail in episode 55 and this demo uses
the same system with some slight
modifications I'd first like to point
out that we have angularfire two
installed and we have auth fire store as
well as the new angular fire functions
module so you'll want to make sure you
have an app module that looks something
like this and you'll also notice that I
generated a payment form component
and project manager component with the
angular CLI that will build out here in
the following steps but the first thing
we'll do is quickly go through the off
service to get our user logged in to our
firebase app one of the key differences
from episode 55 is that we have some
additional properties on the user
interface mainly the stripe customer ID
as well as some information about the
subscription itself we have angularfire
2 installed here so we can inject
angular fire off and fire store in the
constructor and then we'll represent our
user as an observable of a firestorm
--nt if the user is authenticated then
we'll go ahead and retrieve their
document from buyer store otherwise
we'll just return an observable of null
which means the users not signed in the
rest of this demo is compatible with any
auth method and firebase but I'm just
going to use anonymous off because it
requires the least amount of code to set
up what this code here is doing is it's
logging in the user anonymously and then
it's creating a document and fire store
when they sign in for the first time so
all we have to do is bind this anonymous
login method to a button click and we'll
get the user signed in without any
additional work on our end then next
thing we want to do is trigger a
function when the user signs up so go
into the indexed es file in the
functions directory and then we'll
initialize firebase admin and we'll want
to also initialize stripe with our
secret key that we set up in the
environment earlier and these variables
are set up globally in this functions
file because they'll be shared
throughout our three different cloud
functions the first function is the
easiest one to create basically we're
just listening for a new user to sign up
and when that happens we'll take their
firebase user ID use that to create a
new user in stripe and then update the
customer ID that we get back from stripe
on their fire store document so we're
just creating a one-to-one connection
between the firebase user and the stripe
user authentication triggers and
firebase will include the firebase user
ID on the user record object then we'll
call stripe customers create and will
set their firebase user ID as metadata
on the stripe customer that part's
technically optional but it's generally
a good idea to keep track of things
between the two platforms stripe will
respond with an object of the newly
created customer and the only thing we
actually need from that is the
striped customer ID which we can then
use to save on the firestore document so
that takes care of the first turtle now
that we have a striped customer the next
thing we need to do is collect their
payment source and then attach them to a
specific subscription plan to handle
that will use stripe elements which is
the quickest and easiest way to set up a
payment form in your front-end UI the
very first thing you'll do is go into
your index.html file and add the stripe
j/s version 3 to the head of the
document then we can go into our payment
form component and the first thing we
want to do is initialize stripe elements
which really just operates outside the
context of our component so we'll just
add it up here directly in the code this
time you initialize stripe with your
publishable key you don't want to expose
your secret key in your front-end code
and then we'll say stripe elements
create card which will eventually bind
here to a Dom element in angular we can
grab an element from the Dom by using
view child which we'll call our card
form and we'll be using a callable
function in this component so we inject
the angular fire function service after
the view is initialized we'll call card
mount which will have stripe elements do
its thing on this specific Dom element
after the user fills out the form we
need to send the card details to stripe
which will then respond with a token
that we can use to attach the payment
source to the user in our back-end for
that we can call stripe create token and
I'm not showing it here but you should
also handle errors here as well but
assuming we have a valid card we can
then call our callable function which
we'll name start subscription so this is
an alternative to using the HTTP module
and angular normally we would have to
set the authorization header for the
logged end user and then decode it in
our cloud function so the beauty of a
callable function as that we don't have
to do any of that we can just pass in
the source that we get back from stripe
and we'll already know the context of
the user when this function gets
triggered then if we switch over to the
HTML all we have to do is set up a form
and then we'll bind to the submit event
on this form and trigger that Handler
that we just wrote the only other thing
to do is set up a div for stripe
elements to attach to which we can do
with hash card form that takes care of
the front-end code
now we'll write the back-end code for
that callable function we can go ahead
and say functions HTTP on-call and that
gives us access to the data that we pass
from the front end which is the stripe
token that we need to use to attach to
the user and again we have access to the
color of this function which we can get
with context auth UID now that we have
this information we can go ahead and
pull that users document from fire store
which contains the striped customer ID
so now we have all the information we
need to attach the payment token to the
stripe customer we make that happen by
calling stripe create source with the
customer ID as well as the token that we
pass through this callable function and
what we're key I'd like to point out
that we handle errors a little bit
differently than other HTTP functions
instead of sending an error response we
can just throw an error directly and a
callable function will send that back
down to the client but assuming that the
payment source attaches successfully the
next step is to subscribe this user to
our actual plan that we created and
stripe at the beginning of this process
so we'll go ahead and call stripe
subscriptions create and pass in the
stripe user ID as well as the plan that
we want to subscribe them to I'm just
hard coding it here but most likely you
would set that up as an environment
variable or send it through the callable
function and lastly that will respond
with some data and we'll use that data
to update the firestore document so at
this point we have a system where the
user can submit their payment and it
updates their document with the
subscription information from stripe the
final thing we need to do is report
usage to stripe otherwise we're not
going to get paid for anything so in
this app here I've set it up so the user
can create a hypothetical project which
is just creating a new document and
firestore that lives in the project's
collection I'm not really going to focus
on the front end code here because it's
really simple just adding a document to
firestore but you can find the full
source code in the link in the
description the interesting part here is
our third and final cloud function we'll
call this the update usage function and
it will run whenever a new document is
created in the project's collection and
the process is pretty similar we have a
user ID that's
that project document to associate it
with the firebase user so we can then
pull their firestore document
information which has the subscription
information that we need to report usage
to so we'll retrieve the user document
like we did in previous functions and
then we'll call stripe usage records
create and we'll create a new usage
record with the item ID on that
subscription this can be kind of
confusing because you might have
multiple items on a single subscription
for example think about the way firebase
bills you have different quotas for
storage database functions etc and your
billed separately for each that's
exactly the kind of stuff that stripe
billing allows you to do you can send
usage records to stripe one at a time or
you can aggregate them together and send
a higher quantity based on the amount of
volume that flows through your app
you'll need to set a timestamp in UNIX
seconds so convert the JavaScript
millisecond date into point seconds then
it's always a good idea to set an item
potency key which you can do with the
snapshot ID that'll just guarantee that
the user's usage will be consistent even
if this cloud function gets invoked
multiple times which is possible then
the final thing we'll do is update the
users record and fire store just so we
can show an estimated bill for that as
well now whenever you create a new
document in fire store this users bill
will be updated and then stripe will
charge them for it at the end of the
month I've been doing this for a while
and it's pretty amazing that we can
build a feature like this in a
completely serverless way and at zero
cost for us initially when building our
a Minimum Viable Product I'm gonna go
and wrap things up there if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
don't forget to join us on angular
academy today again at 1 p.m. Pacific
time and if you're not already a pro
member make sure to sign up to get
access to all kinds of exclusive content
designed to help you build and ship your
app faster thanks for watching and I'll
talk to you soon